hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
a property investor I've been invited to
let property now for over 10 years and
I've trained tens of thousands of people
to do the same and in this video I want
to tell you the basics of buy-to-let
property investing now listen you might
be thinking I don't wanna know the
basics honor the advanced stuff but
these basics that I'm about to teach you
the five basic foundation fundamental
principles of buy-to-let property
investing are things that 90% of
property investors don't do so although
they're basic to me and they're basic to
my students they're absolutely
fundamentally important so if you're
considering buying a property and
renting out then you must watch this
video till the end also if you like my
videos if you like the channel please
don't forget to smash the like button it
helps the YouTube algorithm also if
you're not subscribed already to the
channel subscribe turn on the
notification bell so you never miss a
future video so the top thing number one
is if you're buying a property you want
to buy it in an area that's trending
that's going to give you expected
capital appreciation now this is what I
mean by this most people what they do is
they wait for properties to go up in
value and then they'll all luck that
area is going up oh wow it's gone up by
50% in the last two years
let's buy there huh and then what
happens is of course it drops and then
they got it dropped oh my goodness I've
lost money and then they sell that is
not what you should do what you should
do is the opposite because what you need
to do is you need to realize that after
a expansion comes a recession and after
a recession comes an expansion so you
want to find areas where properties have
actually gone down quite a lot or are
even going down and it's the or it's the
opposite of what your intuition might
tell you but as an investor this is all
about doing following trends and doing
what's gonna make you money so when the
property's going down you want to go
great and then as it bottoms out and
it's not going up yet you by love by it
low and rent it high so that's tip
number one and again I'm not suggesting
that you buy properties that are in dive
dump all areas which
what we're gonna get onto some of the
other points I'm not saying just by
really really really really cheap
properties the return on investment
needs to work out to what I am saying is
don't get carried away when a markets
going up and think how it's gonna go up
and up and up forever it won't if it's
gone up a lot in the last five years
it's probably gonna drop and it's gonna
correct itself if it's gone down and
it's bottomed out it's probably going to
go up so that's the first thing for
expected capital appreciation however
point to capital appreciation doesn't
pay the bills point to is you need to
make sure that the property is giving
you a high return on investment capital
appreciation in other words properties
that go up in value to that that doesn't
pay the bills
it might make you rich is fantastic but
you can't Bank on capital appreciation
what you can bank on and you can
physically Bank every single month is
cash flow cash is not King cash flow is
king
so you want to what you want to you want
to make sure that your property that
you're buying is giving you money each
and every single month it is not an
asset if it's not putting money in your
back pocket every single month and I
hear people saying you know oh I want to
buy a property there's for capital
appreciation as long as it washes its
face washes its face you know what that
means that means it doesn't have to make
any money it just needs to do pay for
itself
that's a terrible investment the point
of property is that it makes you
financially free it doesn't have to wash
its face it has to pay you every single
month so you need to work out how much
rent is that property going to generate
and how much money are you going to put
down in the first place you're going to
work out the return on investment
now most people work on yield I don't
care about yield yield is what's the
annual rent and what's the purchase
price and you divide the two together I
think that's completely irrelevant so
point two still on point two here is you
need to work out what's the return on
investment the return on investment is
the amount of money that you personally
had to put down so that's the deposit
that's the legal fees whatever you
person gets put down and then you need
to calculate how much monthly profit are
you going to be getting what's the
monthly rent
- management - maintenance and voids -
the mortgage payments the 3m
management mortgage maintenance what's
the rent - those three things that's
going to give you with your gross profit
your pre-tax profit times that by 12
that's your annual profit divide that by
the total amount you put down and that
is the return on investment and that
thing you should be aiming to get 20% or
higher very very important point number
three you want to always buy below
market value the great thing about
property is that you can buy below
market value there's lots of stuff
there's lots of investments like gold
and Bitcoin and where the price is the
price is the price now if property the
great thing is that's not the case the
price is what someone's prepared to pay
for it and the price is what someone's
prepared to sell it for so in property
you want to find motivated sellers you
want to find people that have to sell
quickly and then you want to get the
best possible price you want to get
bargains
so find properties that are already
bottomed out so the market value is low
that are going to cashflow high and then
buy them even lower negotiate the price
down and the way you do that is you do
that by asking the question ask the
question before you even view a property
don't go and view 20 properties and just
put in the cheeky offer before you even
view ask the question what's the sellers
situation you know look I'm an investor
so I don't want to offend anybody but
I'm only likely to be able to offer
around about 80% of the market value is
it worth me booking or viewing or not
how long does that take to say that to
one estate agent like 20 seconds what
happen if you phoned 20 estate agents
today that's like a few minutes
potentially actually a phone time on
this their agent who did that every day
you're gonna find some stage and say you
know what you've hit the jackpot because
this particular seller is really
motivated he's moving to Australia or
he's got a sell sell I think he might
accept your offer come and view it quick
you and then you've got Bank below
market value
you're only phoning for properties that
are in high expected capital
appreciation areas that are gonna give
you high cash flow so that's the first
three points if you enjoying this video
please do smash the like button drop a
comment below subscribe to the channel
smash that like smash that like helps
the algorithm and then more people can
see this message and be smart when it
comes to investments
number four this is so important if
you're starting out by tulip property
investing and that's this by with your
formulas not with your feelings you're
going to struggle to tick every single
box high return on investment high
expected capital appreciation all these
boxes these formulas and also like the
property if you if you're thinking about
lighting the property I like the
property it's got a good feel to it I
like the guy and it's about your
feelings and what you like I can see
myself living here one day if it all
fails and all goes to hit everything
hits the fan you know what I'll move
into my investment property because I
like it that's a bad plan
you want to buy strictly not with your
feelings but with your formulas you want
to buy properties that they're gonna
give you money and then guess what
it's not going to hit the fan and you
won't need to move into it the purpose
of an investment property and as an
investor is you want to buy things that
are going to make you as much money as
possible so do not buy with your
feelings do not get emotionally attached
to a property never be at ease until you
get the keys don't start thinking you
know before completion oh I love this
property and have a little dream board
of it and sit and dream about it cuz
then what happen is the seller will say
oh you know what I've changed my mind
you're gonna have to give me more money
and suddenly you're in a situation
whereby you'll be emotionally attached
and you'll start making when emotions
are high intelligence is low so do not
get emotionally attached point number
five lastly is this you need a good
Power Team and what I mean by a Power
Team is you need a good solicitor a good
accountant a good mortgage broker to get
you the best rates you need a good
estate agent to sell you the deal in the
first place and you need a good letting
agent that's going to manage the
property and make sure that this is a
passive income as opposed to a headache
you can have a hundred houses and it's
unless you've got it
systemize probably it's just going to be
a hundred headaches so work on
relationships or I always say a good
relationship is actually better than a
good deal so my advice to you if you're
thinking about getting into buy-to-let
is find other property investors that
are doing buy to that network go to
networking events go to training
seminars and meet people meet estate
agents ask around get referrals and
build your power team this is a business
this is not a hobby where you just
happen to own a second home if you do
that you're gonna get a hobby like
income if you treat this serious as a
business and build your power team and
equip yourself and educate yourself and
you follow these five points then you're
gonna get because you're treating this
serious as a business you're gonna get
serious business results so that's my
five tips I hope you like it if you want
to see more videos like this please do
let me know in the comments smash the
like subscribe to the channel if you
want to see more videos a bit like this
into a bit more detail you can see a
whole place that I created just for you
the whole playlist is right here and you
can subscribe right here do that
subscribe share the video around thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
next time